the explosive video eight news now first
brought you last month now this atm
thief is suspected in three more crimes
the i-team's david charns here with more
on those cases and the new video police
want you to see yeah it's really
incredible to see here this all playing
out inside a southwest valley salon the
thief leaving with that atm and then
leaving behind quite a mess
yeah you see uh in here you hear what
happened there at the front of the store
collapsing now metro police say the same
smash and grab burglar is behind a
string of these thefts so this is his mo
you see him drive up his car
puts a rope around the atm and then just
drives off taking the atm with him there
he goes detectives say this man is
behind at least four break-ins now
at businesses across the valley since
late october this is some new video that
we got today where the same thing
happens at a different place not only
does he get away but the atm are safe
now four times he causes a ton of damage
there there it happens again in the
videos he is wearing this bright yellow
sweatshirt his truck is a silver or gray
two-door chevy silverado metro hoping
you may recognize this guy we'll have
more on where these smash and grabs
happen coming up new at six i'm david
charns live local now